bueno podemos decir que es un gesto
bastante valiente en un mundo muy
complejo en un contexto muy difícil como
es también en la red ucrania y creo que
está marcando que el futuro si está
igual va a tener un problema luego
tuviera un problema con china de
carácter bélico y eeuu va a estar
apoyando a la democracia está igual esa
hay que mirar con mucha atención un
artículo que publicó hoy
nancy pelosi misma apenas llegar a
taiwán donde explica muy políticamente
su visita y habla un poco reivindicado a
taiwán su democracia que tiene una una
líder mujer que reivindica su lucha con
talco bid en contra comiendo con lo de
china y diciendo que va a defender lo
que taiwán represente sobre lo de su
mensaje muy fuerte en el marco una
política del gobierno norteamericano de
reforzar su posición en la región
pero qué es exactamente lo que
representa taiwán en la región y
respecto a china
bueno con respecto a la región es uno de
los poquísimos países que se consideran
democráticos en esa zona del mundo que
son los menores una zona donde la
libertad de prensa donde organismos como
freedom house reconocen que está igual
es una democracia donde sus ciudadanos
tienen plenos derechos y eso está muy en
discusión y también creo que de alguna
manera es un mensaje a china como como
ella diciendo porque le está diciendo a
china ustedes dicen que violamos el
derecho internacional dice pelosi pero
el derecho internacional no solo cuando
te toca a vos le toca a uno mismo si
china no se define más por ucrania y ahí
no cumple el derecho internacional
tampoco puede reclamar para el caso da
igual me parece y también está la movida
estratégica eeuu pone a china en una
situación de lengua trampa como
reaccionar como un ya no puede romper su
tradicional discurso pacifista
tampoco puede generar demasiada
violencia con una simple visita de una
duda parlamentaria entre comillas no así
que creo que es una movida muy
inteligente parte del gobierno' eeuu y
sin embargo china ya estaba moviéndose
militarmente estamos ya ante una
escalada de movimientos y de tensión con
respecto a taiwán en el ámbito militar o
de defensa o responde simplemente
realmente a movimientos en los que china
pueda decir aquí estamos nosotros frente
a esta visita
bueno acá el contexto nacional de ambos
países es muy importante así como eeuu
tiene elecciones laica pero si va a
renovar su banca próximamente china
también se enfrenta con su partido
congreso a partido comunista donde el
presidente si va a intentar elegir por
tercera vez algo inédito en la historia
reciente de china entonces de alguna
manera china tiene que mostrar algún
tipo de reacción hacia su propia opinión
pública
sobre todo el partido cómo está
dirigiendo el partido laborista entonces
alguna manera sobre estas reacciones
tienen ese sentido no creo que a corto
plazo haya algún tipo de enfrentamiento
violento entre los países y más allá del
ámbito militar y político que ocurre
entre los taiwaneses respecto a su
relación con china para las personas que
no entiendan porque hay un conflicto
entre china y taiwán como nos lo podría
explicar
podríamos decir que el pasado tanto
tiempo de la división entre taiwán y
china hoy en generaciones los jóvenes
las generaciones que viven está igual
hoy desean que taiwán sea un país
independiente decía nunca igual
independiente
mayoritariamente y dependiente de china
hay una identidad propia de los
taiwaneses después de tantos años de
esta situación de autogobernarse
entonces creo que este punto si la
voluntad a los taiwaneses es vivir una
vida independiente de china